[Music]
[Music]
hello YouTube just Louis and her friends
this is guns in here welcome to the 33
episode of dirty chest tricks in this
episode I'm going to show you one of the
Carlson's amazing trick against Sicilian
con or the Hedgehog structure in the
year 2004 a throne of the why Kenzi -
namond Carlson had the white pieces and
he unleashed one of his shock weapon
which later on become more fashionable
he opened up with the movie full and his
opponent responded with the Moose ePHI
and we have the Sicilian con on the
board after the following water that is
Knight to f3 d6 d4 C captors d4 Knight
captures d4 and now the MU a6 Carlson
continued here with one of his pet line
that is c4 Amarok C bind kind of setup
we're quite control the d5 square and
enjoy a slight space advantage black
continues with Knight to f6 attacking e4
Knight to c3 defending and now here
there are two popular choices from the
black one is to play Bishop to b4
combining with the move Queen to c7 and
the second plan which happened in this
game that is d6 and after cousin
fianchetto his King side Bishop with the
moon g3 black continue with the move
Queen to c7 okay Bishop to e3 p6 and now
first critical moment of the game
Bishop to g2 so white is committing the
whole c4 pawn and black dare not to take
it a kalos opponent can easily for
into this because after Queen to c4 and
rook to c1 the opening of the C file
gives a decisive advantage to the white
for example if Quinn to c7 then the
simplest is night to be file and after
Queen to d8 and night to c7 white Vince
the exchange with a winning position and
instead of Queen to c7 if black tried to
become smart and play the move Queen to
b4 then he will be in a bigger trouble
after the following order that is a
three Queen to e5 Knight to b3 Queen to
h5 desperate to exchanging the Queen
but after Bishop 12:3 this position is
completely winning for the white if
Queen to g6 then Bishop to h5 is a very
strong reply and accordingly if Queen to
h3 then Knight to be Phi is winning for
the white finally what happens if Queen
moves let's say to Fi well then after
Bishop to a4 that sweetie is trap at the
center of the ball so it is very clear
that Queen captures c4 leads to some
risky play by black so in the game black
continued with the move Bishop to be 7
and after castle on the King side
continued with his piece development
such as Knight B to d7 rook to 7 and now
Bishop to e7 so black has created this
Hedgehog structure that is a 6b 6d 6 &
e6 which controls the 5th rank and not
only that it's not easy for white to
break through this pawn chain especially
if he is playing for the win blacks idea
in these structures are very simple he
wants to castle and then depending on
the white response he gradually want to
create a pawn break at the right time
before this game the most popular choice
by the white is rope to even where many
game has been drawn
but in this game carlson was in a
completely different mood and he come up
with this exceptional preparation poo so
suddenly from nowhere white is
sacrificing the whole piece and black
has to walk out what he is going to do
about it there are two obvious choices
for the black either take the piece or
run with his queen if Queen to b8 then
the simplest is you take this mission
and after King takes
I think these positions are very easy to
play as avoid the problem here from the
black campus his King is stuck in the
center and on top of everything he has
to defend this VK spot d6 which is not
easy to handle for example a sample line
can run like this
b3 rope to d8 f TV King to f8 Queen to
d2 King to g8 so finally King has done
that if he shall castle but after
White's next apply that is our f2 given
I think Black has a huge problem
defending the d6 and in fact the game in
a very recent game black has tried the
move Queen to d8 which at first sight
looks very natural but against this
White has this another dazzling mu Aoife
so continuing his piece sacrifice mood
with a very good initiative there are
two distinct lines over here first what
happens if you open in capture the pawn
well after this White has this flashy
move Knight captures a six so attacking
two sports
so black responses force black has to
take this 9 but after Knight captures f6
Jack Knight captures up 6 Bishop
captures b7 attacking the rook rook to
b8 and Bishop to e6 after the whole
sequence it turns out that not only
White has extra pawn and a
Japan but black has some horrible bone
structure which is close to loss well
then what happens if you open and take
your piece he kept us defy well against
this wide response is pretty obvious
where it has to take the piece back and
now black has two of his choices if you
take with the night or the Jeep on let's
say Knight captures f6 then the
following condition gives white a very
good advantage that is II kept is defy
castle on the Kings side and now Knight
to c6 and that monster Knight cannot be
kicked away and if black take this nine
then the C pawn will be to square away
from the queening so obviously this is
not a good choice for the black so the
more accurate response here is Bishop
captures f6 and after that White has
this another attacking move Knight to f5
attacking on d6 so black responds his
force black has to play Queen to b8
white will keep pressurizing the d6
square with the move Bishop to f4 and
black can defend this with Knight to e5
so at first sight it looks like there is
no attack to speak off and black is
quite comfortable
well perception can be deceptive and
here why it has this forcing sequence
that is Bishop captures
ePHI if Bishop captures Aoife then f4 is
a very strong reply so the obvious move
is D captures ePHI Queen to e4 check
kindly note if B Phi then Queen to be
full and black has to postpone the
castling for a long time so the correct
continuation here is King to f8 and now
the simplest is you take this pawn so if
you analyze this position right now you
can easily see that this King is
completely misplaced and black PCs are
not coordinated properly I like to show
you one of my game from this position
where my opponent continued with the
move
six attacking my night but I rather
continue with my own attack with Queen
to d7 he gave my peace and I revealed my
idea that is rook to c7 so threatening
mate on f7 my opponent defended with
Queen to e8 but after Queen captures fi
white is attacking to sport and black
cannot defend both of them in the game
he continues with the move King to g7
but after Queen check King to f8 and
rook captures b7 not only black king is
stuck in the center but white has some
easy plan such as rook to see one and
then rope swings to the c7 with a deadly
attack to boot not to mention there's an
outright passer on the D Phi square all
in all this is a wonderful position to
play as a white so from these visions it
is very clear that running with the
Queen is a not a good choice for the
black so the obvious Christian need to
be arise what happens if black accept
this piece
well after that white response is very
obvious what is going to capture with
the C pawn attacking the Queen and if
the night to see fire then B for white
regain the piece with a very good
position so the critical response is
Queen to b8 and this is exactly happen
in this game Carlsen continue with his
initiative with Knight to c6 attacking
the Queen and this is a beauty about
this line is Queen doesn't have any good
spot to hide so black responds is force
black has to take the snide but after D
capture c6 just on the 15th move of the
game obtain a completely winning
position in the game cousins upon and
continue with the move rook to e7
but after pawn captures and Knight
captures not only white obtain a two
bishop pair but black has an horrible
weakness on d6 which Carlsen easily
in the middle game I have attached the
rest of the game in the pgl which you
can check it out
the biggest question arise instead of
sacrificing the piece back what happens
if black tried to save the piece let's
say either Knight to e5 or night to CFI
well to demonstrate the plan of the
campaign from the white side I like to
show you my two games where in the first
game
my opponent continue with the Moon
Knight to e5 I disappointed with the
move c7 attacking the Queen he stopped
the pawn advancement with Quinn to c8
and now another attacking gesture f4 and
I think black is already lost in this
position because after the game
continuation that is Knight to g4
attacking the bishop bishop to d4 and
black plays the obvious move castle on
the Kings side but then he hit by this
wonderful mu E Phi which stands white
victory he kept his e Phi F captures
ePHI night to aid but after Bishop
captures 8 it's very funny that black
cannot even test this bishop because
then white will promote another Queen
probably the most accurate night movies
night to see Phi but after that black
will continue with the MU c7 so the same
idea if Queen captures c7 then the
simplest is you play E Phi attacking to
sports which cannot be defended so
instead of Queen captures c7 the better
movies Queen to see it protecting the a
bishop but nevertheless white will
continue with the mu E Phi attacking to
sports and after D captures ePHI Bishop
captures 8 and Queen captures 8 at first
sight it looks like black obtained two
nights for a rock and the position can
be playable but if I tell you that the
position is immediately winning for the
white
you might get surprised before I move on
I like you to pause this video and find
out a forcing variation which gives Y of
winning age did you find it
let's see Bishop captures c5 Bishop
captures c5 and now the dazzling mo yep
you guessed it rook captures c5
boom-boom
[Music]
well what's the big idea the idea is
after be kept to C Phi Y T is going to
continue with the move Queen to d6 so
not only stopping the castle but the
simple idea is rook to d1
and then checkmate on the d8 square
I got this position against a candidate
master where my opponent continued with
the move Queen to c8 I responded with
the move rook to d1 and now Knight to d7
so at first sight it looks like black
has defined every single thread and
white is a clear piece down right well
that's right
but this is all prepared and here I
continue with the move Queen to c6
so my simplest idea is I want to take
this nine and after Queen takes I will
promote my point to the Queen
so something black has to respond
immediately and I think he played the
accurate response that is king to e7
guarding the Queen and the CH square
but after White's next reply it is very
obvious that black game is not going to
survive longer can you see one of the
most accurate response from here
well the surprising enough
the move is f4 and more you look at this
move you will find out that more poison
it carry
for example if black take this pawn then
Queen to d6 is a very deadly reply and
if the pawn moves forward then Queen
captures efore gives white a winning
attack so in the game after a long
consideration my opponent continued with
the MU app six so safeguarding is ePHI
square
but after the move fi black position is
completely collapsing the game wrapped
up very quickly rook to e8 Queen to d6
check King to f7 Queen captures d7 check
King to f8 and finally the finishing
knot Quinn capture see it black resigns
in the view of rook captures c8 and rook
to d8 and there is no way black and stop
white to Queen the ball well I hope you
enjoy and learn this wonderful night to
defy idea against Hedgehog or the
Sicilian Khan structures look out for
such a moose in your own games which
gives white a great dynamism and play
for the win attack thank you for
watching this video feel free to like
subscribe and comment on my video and
I'll meet you in my next episode very
soon bye and take care